FBI Flags slang terms Chad based red
pilled it's over to Target racially
motivated violent extremists the FBI's
domestic terrorism reference guide on
involuntary celibate violent extremists
offer a threat overview for in cells
that aims identify them by the slang
they use
so uh you thought Biden's 50 Cent Army
was bad yeah you're gonna have a whole
bunch of crackpot cultists getting paid
to promote Democrats now the feds are
going to be targeting you if you say
things like based and that's one of the
reasons your former guest Vivek wants to
eliminate the FBI one of the many
reasons he wants to eliminate I love
that oh my wow this guy's he's pretty
hardcore you know Ron Paul was saying
that many decades ago he was saying that
30 years ago and I think there's
individuals even before that at the very
beginning of the FBI they have a
horrible record especially with J.R de
Hoover especially with what they did to
JFK